let's go instead to our caller from the
two four eight area code whose calling
today from two four eight hi David my
name is true and else hey how's it going
I'm good
so I actually work in the Boston area
now so mmm I'm like originally from
Michigan so yeah it's nice to talk to a
local Boston now good what's on your
mind ah so I just sorta I just wanted
your opinion on the kind of how news is
being shared differently now compared to
like our parents age where they got the
information from MSNBC or like Fox News
my parents are really like into CNN and
MSNBC what do you think of like the new
progressive left voice rising on YouTube
while it kind of seems like the right RT
it did have a voice with like steven
crowder joe rogan and stuff like that a
lot of my friends are into Joe Rogan
like find his views on things very you
know casually moderate I guess in a
sense hmm so do you feel like that kinda
has a leg up where if you kind of
mentioned to people hey I listen to
David Pakman I like the rational
National The Young Turks they're kind of
like oh it's like too far left too
extreme like you know none of us
individually have the name recognition
where there is an immediate connotation
for bringing up oh I listen to David
Pakman or whoever else I mean I think
what's important to understand is that
the right so if you go back and look at
a lot of the academic literature about
AM radio and talk radio the write
effectively had a monopoly on that
platform from the get-go because
structurally and because of the
relationship with regulators and the FCC
the basically am talk radio was almost
completely right-wing and religious for
a very very long time so one thing that
we have to sort of disabuse ourselves of
is the idea that because a platform is
dominated or appears to be dominated by
one side now the idea that that platform
is indefinitely going to be V
agenda-setting platform I think you know
we would all agree that now the inner
that has sort of taken a lot of that
power from AM radio and that things do
change over time nothing stays the same
so that's one thing just to understand
so when we talk about what's going on
right now on YouTube and Internet media
it doesn't mean that it's what's going
to be going on in a few years now I
would sort of challenge your contention
that that being said that the right has
had this big advantage on YouTube and
online from the beginning podcasting a
it the genesis of podcasting I believe
was much more a progressive minded
platform than it was right wing although
there are plenty of important and big
right wing podcasts and I think on
YouTube it's an open question as to
whether the left or the right is
dominating if you look at number of
channels you might get one answer if you
look at total audience size you might
get a different answer so I think that's
that's really a question right now yeah
I guess it's kind of like the the big
names for like Joe Rogan and steven
crowder with their millions of
subscribers and kind of besides the
Young Turks I don't see other lefty
voices that kind of have such a
widespread audience sure I do understand
with that but one is that a lot of those
a lot of the lefty channels are growing
I mean but Kyle kolinsky and I are both
on track to hit you know a million
subscribers in the not crazy crazy
future and so that that's definitely
going to be a change sam cedars channel
is also doing really well but i think
it's also important to understand that
there are channels that are and people
who are really big not because they
necessarily have developed those
audiences organically but because they
have been significantly pushed by
significant funding from entities and
that is much more common on the right
than it is on the left so i think we
just have to really look at those
numbers with a grain of salt and really
kind of understand the broader context
in which they exist but here's the the
question I would have for you either way
like we can't control how many people
are following right-wingers online I
think you would agree all we can do is
do the best content possible as lefties
and get as many people to be listening
to us and watching us as possible we
can't control what they do but we can
control what we do mm-hmm
yeah I guess it's just kind of it's hard
when everyone kind of sees
Joe Rogan Erlich steam cards just like
jokingly cool guys that have like fun
views and they smoke weed and everything
but it's harder they go out especially
and I think that was a big argument in
fact with Rogan yeah well I mean just
for Joe like that's like kind of like
you know he's like a chill guy with
bright wings some rhyming dudes or ideas
but like it's kind of hard to say hey
check out like this David Pakman clip to
people who are in that sphere and it's
just kinda it's guess just worrisome
that like people find Joe Rogan more
like the norm I see when talking to
people instead of like some of the other
voices out here on YouTube so that's
kind of like where my question came from
originally but I didn't point from what
you've been saying about more I mean
there's no question Rogen is definitely
seen as sort of like the everyman and
you can kind of get behind a lot of what
he says because he's just kind of like
another guy next door that you're
talking to the truth is the majority of
Rogen's views are pretty much left wing
views but they're presented in a style
in which it's less obvious and then
every once in a while he will drop in
something that seems kind of right right
wing okay thank you for the call really
appreciate hearing from you great to
hear from callers in the Boston area and
hope to hear from you again in the
future